[Music]
how is fatherhood going for you enjoying
fatherhood I do enjoy it it's difficult
it gets easier though it's one of those
things that gets easier I had a dog once
and that doesn't get easier it doesn't
it's harder having a dog because
children develop and dogs just stay dumb
and they never figure it out and when
you're done yeah I don't know we ever
had a dog that's had a medical problem
but you can't get their cooperation when
you need to help them because you can't
sit him you know you have this problem
you see yeah I had this dog when I took
my dog to the vet the first time she was
I don't know a year old when I adopted
her and the vet told me don't let your
dog eat dark chocolate I don't know if
you know this but I've heard this that
yeah it's dark chocolate supposed to be
poison to dog kills him and vets won't
explain it further either it's like why
does it kill him well just say die like
they won't tell you what like what do I
do if my dog eats dark chocolate watch
her die or leave the room but the the
vet did tell me there's one thing you
can do which is give your dog a hydrogen
peroxide and that foams up in the dog's
belly and then they throw it up with the
chocolate that's what you should know to
do that
but you gotta do it quickly before they
ingest the chocolate all right so I come
home like six months later sure enough
my dog gets our chocolate I had friends
would stayed over and they didn't know
they left dark chocolate in low places
which is very
[Music]
there's a good place I could put it on
this high shelf
I may be crawling on the floor later
might need a snack so what so you know
my dog and your dog eating the whole big
bar of dark Holies chocolate the Polish
part doesn't matter but I like saying
Polish chocolate and my dog had
chocolate on her face and and I went oh
my god and she looked at me like I was
home for an hour alone what are you
gonna you know come on and I was like
you're gonna die and she's looking at me
like I don't understand English but I
get that you're upset and hydroxide into
this dog but I don't have any so I've
got to go to the pharmacy and she needs
to come with me cuz there's no time I'm
in New York City and I take my I put the
leash on her she's like excited we're
going for a walk and I'm running and
she's like this is great for you you
never exercises she's just enjoying it
and then we get to the pharmacy and
she's waiting for me when I come out and
I've got a bottle of hydrogen peroxide
that I have to make her drink yeah
like take yourself through that how do
you make a dog like you just here drink
this you know so I kind of pour a little
in her snout she goes like that and so I
kind of grabbed her and I pour once she
she goes I think it was pretty clear
that I didn't like that like she looks
at me like and so I get my whole body
around her this dog was 70 pounds she
was like an alligator if she didn't want
to drink something
she's just thrashing on my frankart and
at one point I have her on the end of
the leash and she's looking at me all
wet in the face and she gives me this
look like I don't know what happened to
you but our thing is over
I'm a dog and she starts going alright
she became completely vicious just
trying to bite me and I'm trying to save
her life yeah so I'm literally I'm
punching her in the face
and people I look and there's hundreds
of people in the sidewalk just cars
stopping there she's gonna die I'm like
it was a nightmare and finally I got
enough in up her nose and whatever and
she was like dude and then she's just
like a pump just Boop and just bring
ahead yeah Brown like she's like another
dog is coming out of her and she made it
but she never liked me after that
because from her point of view I just
went no went nuts I lost my no reason we
have to take a commercial break more
with Louie CK in just a second
[Applause]